[Applause]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone be cool blogging blogging this
is Fred Irie
I'm we're here Tyler Ward and we're
about to make a video for his channel
making noise with things in the room
that's beautiful music right that's
gonna be my new ringtone it's a record I
guess recording I have been terrible at
vlogging mostly because thank you thank
you repressed woman the daytime
I've been terrible vlogging because I
keep forgetting my camera with me so I'm
just using my phone right now I'm headed
to meet mamrie we've been having a lot
of business meetings and there's a moss
like there's a souped-up Mazda that just
sounds like a tiny little motorcycle in
front of me is that the correct cards
are shoot dub I go for some soup cold -
Chris bacio it's hot
no I wake up every morning craving sushi
but that's a truck just carrying dirt
going somewhere like that's the real
reason trucks exist so they can carry
[ __ ] like just pure dirt now learning it
is 8:40 a.m. right now and I managed to
a me dating with Hannah Hart and
Hannibal a good friend of Hannah's from
when
they were both younger up in Northern
California I don't know why I like
giving you Wikipedia pages information
for but that may this morning I did not
sleep well last night because I couldn't
sleep so I watched Donnie Darko ain't
that movie as freaks the [ __ ] out of my
butt so I could not sleep one in the
darkness and then two at all really
so let's go to a meeting
oh he just threw trash over if I do this
that kid right there just threw garbage
into the water
the meetings over I did not film Hannah
or Hannibal live it ain't happened I
swear I'm not just driving aimlessly by
myself I can see that but that truck is
the bug man's truck and she slogan is
it's a great day at the bug man I don't
that it's not you
clever when you sold them in a car again
how exciting is this and it's the same
day but I've put eyeliner on so much of
it and changed my clothes I'm off to
another meeting this time with me I
didn't tell you guys that this is fun
look at this my friends are here what do
you call a democratic cheese a sharp
left hello
so I just finished dinner with Hannah
and Molly me Molly and Sarah and
Hannibal and I didn't film it because I
hate giving us content apparently
and before that I had a drink with
mamrie didn't film that I just you know
I don't I just want it to be you and I
know I'm just I forget
I enjoy the reality of being around
people sometimes back in the car I do is
actually Friday I are so tired last
night when I got home then I fell asleep
before I edited my video and then I woke
up and had a bunch of calls today and so
I figured I'd just keep it going
why not this is like a vlog bender
that's good
I mean at least I don't wake up hungover
I'm going to yet another two meetings
with mamrie and I swear I'm try and get
that [ __ ] on camera not [ __ ] she's
wonderful wonderful woman
I forgot the film Avery finally got
mamrie on camera finally a very shot I
literally I've been driving and
recording myself driving to every
meeting we've had and be like I'll get
mine be on camera and then I forget and
I get in my car and I'm like I didn't
get it on camera
there's
Blaze's a breed is bright and this
really yeah
yes big time look sneak a check surprise
things are happening you'll know
hashtag soon also other hashtags we
should be saying it later
oh also I don't know
[Music]